so as we get into our final video on the
first act of Darkseid war I wanted to
take some time to answer a few questions
that you all had in the comments of the
last video and videos before it some of
you had expressed some confusion about
both Foom Jessica Cruz and the
difference between her and the Green
Lantern and so what we're going to do
here is run over the changes Geoff Johns
has made with the origins of the
universe and then wrap around into
voloom jessica cruz and the ring of
voloom itself as sue if you recall my
video on the guardians of the universe
we had talked about the origin of the
universe as it was written during the
crisis on Infinite Earths
in that story we were told that during
the guardians early years one of their
member named Crona had used the
technology of the time to look back to
the point of the positive matter
universes creation as a result his
actions spawned the formation of the
antimatter universe where evil reign
supreme and while this act forced the
guardians to banish Crona and form the
Manhunters and eventually the Green
Lantern Corps to safeguard the positive
matter universe from the introduction of
evil it also saw the formation of the
anti-monitor who was then used as a plot
device for the crisis on Infinite Earths
story now this was a standard origin
from crisis on Infinite Earths in 1985
going forward as part of the new 52 we
launched Geoff Johns came back and ret
canvas during the events of wrath of the
first Lantern from 2013 we're told that
when Corona used his device to look at
the origin of the universe rather than
his actions resulting in the formation
of the antimatter universe and the
anti-monitor instead his observation of
the universe's creation brought the
arrival of a mysterious being named
Volvo now the origin of all phoom is
actually unknown and may be explained at
some point in the future by Geoff Johns
or another writer but with volumes
arrival came knowledge of the emotional
spectrum of will power rage love fear
compassion avarice hope life and death
now where each of these emotions would
go on to form the basis behind their own
respective Lantern cores because well
phoom had demonstrated the ability to
tap into and control the entire
emotional spectrum he had fashioned his
own ring called the ring of all foon and
stood as the first Lantern however
because he began to demonstrate a love
for tormenting the souls of all living
things combined with his ability to
manipulate reality the guardians became
fearful of the danger he represented and
locked both theme away wiping all
knowledge of his existence from history
now where the wrath of the first Lantern
storyline centered on his return the
conclusion of the story saw his defeat
but also saw his ring being sent into
the earth 3 continuity where it found
that universes version of Hal Jordan
now what DC did here was established the
spirit of Ulthar remained inside the
ring and fed off the fear of its wielder
while simultaneously allowing them to
use its power as a result for all
intents and purposes the ring is the
same as a Green Lantern ring regarding
its abilities but differs and that it
will eventually kill its user however
when the anti-monitor began making
battle plans for his war against
Darkseid and attack the earth 3 universe
the super-powered inhabitants of that
reality fled which kicked off the
forever evil storyline now degree
forever evil when Herald Jordan and the
crime syndicate fought against Lex
Luthor and the injustice league Sinestro
had battled Jordan and in the process
ripped his arm off as a result Jordan
lost his ability to use the ring at
which point it began to search for
another host eventually finding and
attaching itself to Jessica Cruz having
said all that and regarding this final
video of the Darkseid war proper as we
get into this we actually open up with
one woman's story of gee Lowe's the god
of laughter now I'd like you to keep
this particular moment in mind because
the end of the story will be a major
source of debate among readers but what
John's does here is coincide the story
of gialos with the appearance of the
Joker what we're told is that according
to one woman's mother there was one
Greek god she hated above all others and
that this God was jealous the reason for
her hatred was rooted in the fact that
rather than being rational all the
adventure like Zeus Ares or even Athena
jiho's took enjoyment in the pain and
suffering of others and while none of
them could see him he always existed in
the background laughing at the misery of
the Amazonian suffering and the loss of
their warriors in battle the reason for
John's providing us with the emphasis on
G loss comes with the fact that the
identity of the Joker seems to haunt
Batman now something I want to point out
here is that John's is not explicitly
telling us that the Joker is the
personification of the Greek god of
laughter this is simply an instance
where we're being told of the underlying
theme of Batman's focus is the Joker and
who he truly is now picking up with
Bruce himself along with Hal Jordan who
was accompanying him on his journey we
joined the two with her arrival in the
earth 3 continuity
what Batman tells us is that when the
anti-monitor had laid waste to this
planet
he had fed on the energies of the
planet's inhabitants on his journey to
earth and preparation for his battle
against Darkseid in addition to this the
basis behind Batman and Jordan being
here is due to the fact that Bruce is
attending to retrace the steps of
anti-monitor to the point of his origin
however the discussion between the two
is also of incredible importance
regarding how Jordan himself according
to Jordan ever since Batman came into
possession of the möbius chair he has
effectively lost his humanity and
instead seems to view himself as above
everyone else now if I can inject my own
opinion here I would say that the
depiction of Batman here only highlights
what was already there throughout his
history
Bruce has always been ridden in a manner
that depicted him as being more
intelligent and capable than the rest of
the league and even within those of his
own bat family the fact that he's now in
possession of knowledge regarding all
things past and present somewhat just
throws this concept into sharp relief
however for Bruce he effectively makes
the case that the arrogance he displays
is not without reason using his access
to the knowledge stored within the chair
combined with his own experience batman
forces Hal Jordan to see the truth of
his character and that his life has
never amounted to anything instead how
was simply bumbling along as a test
pilot until he stumbled upon the ring in
addition to this his role as a Green
Lantern has been tumultuous at best with
events like Emerald Twilight seeing him
destroy the Lantern Corps and kill the
guardians of the universe furthermore
because Batman states that the ring is
the true hero and that Hal Jordan would
be incapable of being anyone of
significance without it his life outside
of the Lantern Corps has no real value
and instead is quite literally devoid of
anyone or anything of meaning now this
is something that I found particularly
interesting and is actually something I
want to focus on for a few minutes
while the ring is capable of incredible
power the ring itself is not a hammer or
random object that can simply be wielded
by anyone the Green Lantern ring
requires willpower and the fact that how
is able to wield it to such a degree and
become one of the most celebrated Green
Lantern's in history is a testament to
both his strength of character and
ability to endure hardships and
temptation that would normally engulf
others and so with Hal Jordan any of the
argument for the purpose of simply
continuing on with their journey
Batman reveals that in order for the two
to locate the origin of the anti-monitor
and learn the answers to their questions
they have to travel to the antimatter
universe and the planet of cord now
transitioning back to the battle between
anti-monitor and Darkseid the conflict
is brought to us in a manner that shows
that the Justice League are not
considered a threat of any real
magnitude with cyborg commenting on this
fact the battle shifts its focus to
Grail what this tells us is that the war
between the forces of anti-monitor and
Darkseid are quite literally all hands
on deck and that the actions of the
Justice League are tantamount to
throwing a cup of water on a burning
house with Grail doing battle against
Kalibak we learn the dark sides pursuit
of Grail wasn't for the purpose of
killing her and then instead he had
simply intended to capture her alive
what we also learned here is that were
Calla backed Hans career with his
intention to torture her in unimaginable
ways including gouging her eyes out
Grail turns the tables on him by
blasting him with her Omega beams and
incinerating his eyes and his own
sockets as a result this brief action
was enough to allow anti-monitor to
temporarily gain the upper hand against
Darkseid now moving to apocalypse johns
continues to close out the lingering
plot threads in quick fashion by
focusing on Superman and Lex something
I'd like you to notice here is that when
the question is asked by Lex as to what
happened to Clark his initial response
is that he's simply been recharged by
the solar pits of Apokolips but with his
physical form changing along with the
introduction of a cruel demeanor the
indication here seems to be that the
pits have corrupted Superman turning him
into an evil version of his normal self
this appears to be evidenced by the fact
that Clark begins to taunt Lex during
their conversation Superman states that
using his super senses he can tell that
Lex is scared of the current situation
and the fact that a Superman chose to
attack him there's likely nothing he
could do
furthermore were like states that he
will fight if it comes down to it Clark
makes the case that the only reasons Lex
has ever defeated him in the past was
because he was simply holding back now
moving back to the Battle of the
anti-monitor and Darkseid we get an
emphasis on three different aspects of
the battle the first comes with Wonder
Woman and Grail followed by Scott free
in Kanto as well as Jessica Cruz and
with the first you were pretty
straightforward with no real room for
discussion I want to take some time to
focus on jessica because jessica is in
possession of the ring which is
inhabited by the spirit of voloom she's
taunted by the whole thing with the
statement that if she chooses to stay
and fight that her fear will overcome
her and that she'll die in the process
however for her character everything
that she's experienced has led up to
this moment requiring her to face her
fear and the fact that she may die what
I mean here is that prior to her
acquisition of the Ring jessica was
someone who constantly ran away from her
problems and never truly face them
head-on where this situation would
normally be an instance where she would
simply run instead she chooses to stay
and battle her fear of dying and the
unknown that comes with it and doing so
she's able to unleash the full power on
whoa Foom but the entire situation is
actually short-lived
with Darkseid summoning the black racer
now this tidbit of knowledge won't
actually be added until the first issue
of Darkseid war Act two with issue
number 45 but in order to make
everything makes sense we're going to
throw it in now
what we're told is that within the new
52 continuity when Darkseid had
established apocalypse
he had harnessed an aspect of death but
because the only way to communicate and
control it was to force it to bond with
a host Darkseid used several individuals
over the course of time to serve as a
host and have the entity carry out his
wishes as such within the context of
this story Darkseid is summon the black
racer for the purpose of killing the
anti-monitor from here the story
provides us with a kind of long shot of
Batman and Hal Jordan along with the
battle on earth while simultaneously
establishing the origin of the
anti-monitor what we learn is that where
the anti-monitor hails from the
antimatter universe at some point he who
created the Mobius chair for the purpose
of observing and recording the origin of
the antimatter universe itself however
when this happened he inadvertently
released the anti-life equation a source
of energy that allows its wielder to
control the wills of others as a result
the equation bonded itself to the
anti-monitor who in turn developed the
power to bend others and force him to do
his will using this ability the
anti-monitor stops Barry Allen in his
tracks
takes control of the black racer and
forces the two to bond together
transforming Barry Allen into the god of
death and so as the first act comes to
an end the anti-monitor uses his version
of the flash to quite literally punch a
hole through Darkseid killing him in the
process
now regarding what I said earlier in
this video about keeping the beginning
in mind something when a woman says as a
story closes is that she was able to
hear laughter now this particular
statement is a major source of
contention among fans and the reason why
is because some claim that John's is
telling us that the Joker is laughing
while others say this is not the case in
truth until John's comes out and tells
us one way or another we don't really
know but in addition to posting any
questions you might have regarding what
we've discussed here let me know what
you think is the Joker the god of
laughter or is g.low simply a completely
separate entity unto himself and with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and that will catch
you guys later
puse